nous sommes engagés dans une guerre
cette guerre pour le moment n'implique
pas des hommes armés elle implique des
renseignements un événement important
s'est produit
on a arrêté un espion soviétique on
voudrait que vous le défendiez je
défends des assurances je n'ai pas
plaider au pénal depuis des années vous
avez représenté beaucoup d'hommes
accusés d'espionnage ce sera une
première pour nous deux vous devriez
être prudent tout le monde a peur de cet
homme il est une menace pour nous tous
comment va nous regarder comme la
famille d'un homme qui essaie de faire
grincer un trade on a tous le droit
d'être défendu
chaque personne est importante
à partir de maintenant vous
n'appellerait plus lu deux avions de
reconnaissance
vous allez prendre des photos aériennes
du territoire soviétique
dites moi ce qui s'est passé ils ont
notre pilote espions la tête plein
d'informations classifiées
nous avons un organe vous allez négocier
les changes sont au gouvernement nous
contacter vous pourriez empêcher une
guerre thermonucléaire total avec l'urss
je vous parle de la sécurité de notre
pays
oublie-t-il que cette négociation ait
lieu exactement vers la teste
dis moi que tu ne courra aucun danger
qui moi quelque chose de précieux je le
fais pour nous il ya peu de routes
ouvertes pour passer à l'est et l'état
de droit est moins respectée là bas en
général éviter d'entrer en contact avec
les gens vous êtes à l'étranger nous
devons avoir la discussion que nos
gouvernements ne peuvent pas avoir
vous êtes américains vous pourriez être
emprisonné surtout éloignez-vous du mur
franchissez le ils vous diront dessus
mais il y a des gens qui ne veulent
absolument pas que cet échange se fasse
on ne laissera pas ici les choses ont
commencé à dégénérer
tout cela un prix à payer pour tout pays
des tatamis
il faut que ce soit un échange